greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happening now is brought to you
by on it for all your supplemental needs
on it is there whether it's alpha brain
shrimp export or shroom tech immune
unless I live off that [ __ ] immune
[ __ ] when I fly you know how this you
don't want to get germs from people you
scratch your [ __ ] ass you sniff your
finger next thing you have to [ __ ]
flu anyway go to [ __ ] on it take a
look at all the supplements they have I
don't deal with the metal I can't help
you with the metal nothing like that but
the elk sausage all that type of stuff
delicious to supplement go to alikom
impress in church CH you are CH and get
em person are delivered to your house I
know you start in you Jitsu I get emails
every day thank you for the listen you
want a tough dependable you want to help
me go to Fuji sports.com right now happy
all-purpose like D $96 I'm gonna give
you 10% off or go full [ __ ] blast at
the super ego or the sakai as eki
the 2.0 then I'm [ __ ] around uni
shinguards you need a mouthpiece you
need [ __ ] portable kettlebells like
that that they're weightless kettlebells
you can travel with them fuji sports
comm is where to go they got tips i'm
dieting they got everything go to fuji
sports calm right now i'm press in
church and get 10% off your next one
delivered to your house you helping up
to church take this [ __ ] meal with
you it's a beautiful day to be alive
monday and we have somebody in studio
that I can't even describe our excited I
am and mr. Henry Rollins what's happened
beautiful it's good to be here it's
great to have you know I was telling
Heidi the brain supreme behind the
scenes yet Winston Churchill once said
success is moving from area to area with
great enthusiasm huh and you are the
[ __ ] living embodiment of that thank
you you don't get bored at anything my
number one question for you before we
even how the [ __ ] do you go from Berlin
in 83 getting hit in the head with a
[ __ ] bottle and being the nicest guy
in the world I mean about it I get hit
in the head in the bottle
I'm doing karate kick some bits you
asking them why they did this to you
that you had never done anything fun
before which was just a beautiful
composure to have as a young man a
cigarette shot that guy that guy he's
such a great shot and now 12 years later
because this is what I go through you're
on a set now 11 years later you're on a
set opposite Buffalo Bill Bill
Buckingham or whatever the [ __ ] the guys
name and he said he's from Buffalo New
York I did a live long if y'all right I
used to torment them and Robert De Niro
and you're sitting there on the trail
and you're looking at today were gone 12
years ago I was in Germany getting hit
in the head with a [ __ ] bomb and
today I'm drinking pomegranate juice you
know well that I come from the minimum
wage working world of the late 1970s I
graduated high school in 79 and went
right into the longer version of summer
jobs which I always had but this was
like 40 hours 50 hours 300 for keeps and
I just figured the rest of my life was
gonna be jobs like this because I had no
I had no direction I didn't want to be
like a sailor or spaceman a banker I
just now let's work these jobs that are
hard on the feet live on top ramen
noodles and live in an apartment with my
roommate that smelled of our laundry
because you Hughes working to and so I'd
worked nice he'd work days we kind of
see each other passing by and um
black flag was pals of mine and I did
they needed a singer and they said yeah
you're pretty crazy he won't audition
and I looked at I was 20 I look like
Flags out here yeah but they were a tour
and you're living in DC Washington yeah
and they're on tour I kinda knew him
from like months before they came
through DC and and they said you're
you're pretty crazy you want to audition
I'm like that's my favorite band and I
looked at my life like well there's a
probably a job like this tomorrow if I
quit this one
you know 375 an hour and so I auditioned
and they said okay you're in and
suddenly everything was different I said
so what do I do
they go you quit your job you pack a bag
you give all your stuff away and here's
a tour itinerary meet us as soon as you
can and within several days I was on a
Greyhound bus from DC - Detroit I still
have the bus ticket met you know I quit
my job giving away all my stuff gave my
records to my best
and said hold onto these in case I ever
come back here I had no idea what was
gonna happen next and within two weeks
I'm living in a punk-rock squat here in
Hollywood because we didn't have a place
to stay and so I kind of come from I'll
try anything because I'm not supposed to
be in a movie or a TV show or on a stage
so anything I'm supposed to be with an
apron on putting extra fries with your
shake and so I just say yes to stuff and
I'm 57 and to this day it's all still
kind of surprising to me okay you want
to be in this I'm like yeah just go do
it but I'm not ever telling you I'm an
actor I'm in this I mean it's like I'm
showing up and saying yes because it'll
probably all end next week
you got always figure and that's kind of
my story is like yeah I'll try that
because I have nothing to lose nothing
you are like oh no and that's the way I
look at my life yeah I look at you first
time I heard he was in Boulder with
music wise friend of mine I Snoopy
a girl turn me on at the black flag she
also turned me on to the first Biggie
Smalls out just to let you know the the
contrast eclectic and her [ __ ] world
and you know I'm like this is punk rock
I'm [ __ ] sex is all what do you think
it is and then the second gentleman
introduced me to you was mr. Doug
Stanhope when I was out here in 1997 he
was gonna watch you somewhere something
something you were doing and I was and
he put you on you know the thing I think
he had an album I don't know what the
[ __ ] that was and you thought you said
something that whatever you were told
him I something about music the
connection hey you will have I'm not a
tough guy you know I come across like a
tough guy when I'm a sweetheart my [ __ ]
can I fear everything and I came from
another country and what made the bridge
for me complete television opened up my
eyes but the bridge was the [ __ ]
music you know you made a statement that
your records never picked on you
your albums never made fun of you
December 5 yeah the record collection
Semper Fi it never abandons you your
friends they come and go sometimes you
have to assume yeah there's that but
your records they always stand straight
at attention waiting for you to deploy
and they don't care if you play them
over and over and if you take good care
of them they'll take good care of you
fact you can be kind of abusive to them
and they'll still kind of hang in there
so you said that and it just destroyed
my insides because I think that's one
thing that has been taken away from the
American child today
the ability to save six bucks from my
left [ __ ] yeah Apryl route and walk two
miles to an album store - by the way
this robust skip lunch by the record
lunch yeah I did that and you cannot
wait to get home and put the album on
without drugs this is way but not right
now and just read the lyrics and thank
you to the Sheraton for providing us you
know if you read the old Van Halen's
I'll always thank the Sheratons and
that's been taken away from us that's an
experience that yeah it's one the
downsides of streaming and digital I
mean for me there's upsides to any
advent in any technology that I deal
with which is audio for sure so online
music and streaming allows you to be
curious and not have to buy the record
like I want to hear Charlie Parker so
you can go online and listen to some
great sides of Charlie Parker like
that's my new favorite musician and go
get the record or like not for me but
you didn't spend 30 bucks buying a
record you can't use and so I like that
but rarely does your internet curiosity
lead to a purchase and so I like it when
you hear some young band you like them
go buy the record that bands in a van
starving right now
like buy two copies and when they come
to town go to the show and that's how
going to the record store was for me
growing up you'd buy the record and
you'd see a flyer that bands coming to
town of course you're gonna go and I did
a lot of well it's can be a three mile
through the snow walk home or I can get
the the second Van Halen record which
was like that was kind of how I got that
records five five bucks in those days
1888 when I bought that record but like
you know you look at your money like
okay and you just walk through the snow
and you get home freezing with that
record and it was never not worth it and
I the fact that you can destroy them
pretty easily if you don't take good
care of them you recommend it gave me
responsibility the first thing I ever
valued is a kid like I'm not gonna screw
this up one of my records everything
else skateboards bikes I would just
recommend like it's like seven dollars
for this single business from England
and that was like a third of the day's
pay to get that right ear two minutes of
angry music and I treated that thing
like a Ming Vaz and I've had some of
these records about 40 years and they
kind of look like the day I got them
because I valued that and I think a lot
of that goes away when you can have a
streaming account because these music
just becomes this thing that comes out
of your phone and it's not what Robert
Plant wanted you to hear when he made
that record he didn't want you here at
mp3 through your phone through the the
headphones that came with your phone
that's what I love about you that you
have respect for the artist yeah that
has been lost somewhere along the line
like I'm the same way you know Robert
Plant did not want this yeah hey I'm the
same way it's an older idea it's an
older value set basically yeah well you
know you and I would hike to the record
store and you'd sit in there and get
burned by the snarky guy behind the
counter like what's that record well if
you knew anything like dude just sell me
something good
oh we get like harsh doubt by these
record store guys they eventually like
because I hang out so long and ask so
many questions they saw that I was a
true record fanatic and they were
begrudgingly more nice to me but a lot
of that is gone and the the mecca of the
record store where you'd walk in and
there's always like those three guys
with no lives hanging around by the
counter commenting on what everybody's
buying like well you know he was better
in 76 like just as an older guy I am I
don't do that at record stores but I am
one of those guy am one of those guys
only have to like bite my tongue yeah
you have the other one why you getting
that that sucked that yeah everybody
knows that he'd left a band before
exactly he was having personal issues
but and the guys look at you like who
gives a [ __ ] of me in personal I'm
telling you now I'm winning I do this I
go to atomic that's a grace for right
here
which I really like a lot of records
from great people what you know you go
to you again
I love amoeba yep on sunset boom go
almost every Friday when I can do you
really yeah and what do you drop there
like I don't mean that
this time they always get you the last
time I was there I did three hundred and
twenty six dollars just because you you
gotta have those record you gotta have
those right I did eight hundred in cash
the other day in Melbourne Australia
said eight hundred Australian so it's
more like six hundred American but I
didn't hesitate I had to have those
records when I spend money you can tell
by the way I dress I'm not spending a
lot of money on clothes I Drive a Mazda
6 when I spend money it's mainly records
why you're very in anything I've watched
about you you carry that [ __ ] work
ethic of yours like a [ __ ] torch what
most people can you know talk to you
about being a Jehovah Witness like if I
let you you would not know people's
doors and tell them the importance of
getting your hands dirty did you have a
paper route yeah
Jesus Christ first job ever head paper
route my introduction to the pyramid
schema like you'll throw eighty million
papers and somehow you'll get forty
bucks I had that happen that's how I got
my first bike saved up for my Schwinn
bike I looked at it in the Sears catalog
maybe it's the Sears bike who's Green
and I'd look at it every day in that big
catalogue you get in the mail and
finally I had the money I took the bus
up Wisconsin Avenue to the Sears bought
the bike it looked just like in the
picture and I wrote at home and it got
stolen a day later but I bought it by
throwing the Washington star and dan
Rather was one of my customers that's
right you're a DC guy yes right I put a
new I knew his son too is my age Dan jr.
but um I used to put a paper on on the
great Dan Rather's porch hey you carry
that my next album CDs gonna be called
immigrant mentality you know I've been
talking about it a lot because it's when
I finally started having a little
success is because I threw my immigrant
mentality in that and I'll tell you
something I read done a DNA test
no yeah I did it was there Mexican or
Puerto Rican
your family or a Cuban because you have
Spanish work ethic why you know you were
telling one story that you on the
weekends you'd work 40 hours you were in
school and you'd have keys to open up
business yeah by the time I was a
sophomore in high school I had the keys
to like a few businesses like they gave
me a big responsibility because they
knew I'm not gonna steal no way and I
could do the inventory I could do the
cash I could make the deposit and so I
was not great in school but I have like
adult responsibilities that are really
valued I didn't care about school I
didn't like it but on I'd work like
three or four days a week after school
and then on the weekends I'd work 9:00
to 5:00 at a pet shop run home shower
jammed down the street and be an usher
from 6:00 to midnight at a movie theater
and then on Sundays I'd work a day at a
surf shop selling skateboards and
repairing stuff and then Monday morning
bright and early back to school and then
on the summer I would like triple up on
all those jobs and just work kind of
seven days a week so I liked earning my
own money
I liked the autonomy of that I mean I
didn't spend it much but I liked earning
it it was not about like I have more
money than you is about I am making my
way in the world and this has gotta be
preparation because I just figure when I
get out of high school it's gonna be
really hard for me I'm gonna have to be
really tough and there's learn about
what a big workweek is like because I
just figured I'm an idiot
and I'm not gonna I'm not gonna go to
college and survive I'm not gonna go
into the military I'm not gonna have a
bank job I'm not gonna be the straight
world is gonna be really hard to me it's
gonna be tough and so I'm gonna have to
get ready for that and luckily both my
parents they're extraordinarily
hard-working people like they're brutal
like my dad is like scorched earth he'd
work all night take a bus back to his
place shower shave new Brooks Brothers
suit go back to the office and my mom
worked for the government so she was
overworked and underappreciated for
entire career and I'd go to visit him on
the weekends Monday through Friday with
my mom Saturday and Sunday with the dad
and all of them all weekend they're just
reading briefs both of them I mean the
weekend was getting ready for Monday and
I just got a lot from that was like you
just work all the time and the
never had to tell me twice to get a job
I never had an allowance I didn't want
it I liked my own money if a guy has the
cool pants from the gap like those
painters pants you like in the 70s I'll
buy a pair I'll be cool like the kids by
my own skateboards I just dug my own
money I didn't want an allowance and I
did I find you know I break leaves
whatever it took I just like being kind
of in the adult world around adults like
seeing how money gets made
seeing how like things get ordered I
worked in an ice cream store I learn
about inventory and how to make the
thing move better I made the guy more
money because I had the place set up for
high-volume sales keep get the line out
quicker and I just enjoyed all of that
now you 57 you you sent thousands of
times you not interested in get married
or are children if you were to have
children were you would still the same
values and principles of work ethic that
you would have regardless of money or
whatever how would you raise that child
carefully because my parents were very
hard driven people and I don't know if a
kid was really in their plans their kind
oh no well so what do we do with this
one I mean they they weren't awful
people I'm just saying they were like Oh
kid okay so what do you what do people
like you like I we like SpaghettiOs in
the Smithsonian I mean they're so busy
and so I was a parent I would not want
to raise my kid like that
I'd be more like my old friends from DC
who grew up and have kids now they're
really there for that kid like we're
doing the thing on Saturday and then we
got this and he has the homework we're
gonna go through it and like wow you're
really being responsible and so if I had
a kid I'd have to radically change my
life because I would see it as my duty
I'm not gonna go on tour I'm not gonna
do like I do at 14 month-long tours
come back for now and then but I'm not
gonna be talking on a tour bus to my kid
after a show Billy where's dad Oh dad's
in Buffalo well in the screw that dad
should be with the kid and that's us how
I see it and so I would I don't want to
change how I live so I wouldn't go on
that venture unless I was willing to
just radically change my life
to not be a bad dad because kids they
don't know kid does asked to get born
they kind of come out and like dude hook
me up with a life here I like my wife
but before you know it I had no idea
they told me if you smoke pot you got no
spells I smoked pot with three hands she
comes in the office and man says you
knocked me out this was not my plan I
had a child when I was young I failed as
a father the wife won't talk to me the
kid won't talk to me I am that big my
child support I did my legal operations
it just didn't work out because of my
career I wasn't ready for it I had to
pick one today I only work on the road
six days a month you know I leave here
at four and take it to karate and she's
five she just won't lost a second tooth
when I was on the fall of us fight
yeah I'm saying yeah dad she kept saying
tell him tell that guy that I lost my
other tooth I didn't want to tell her it
was late because then she wasn't said
but I feel like it's my obligation but
I'm also at five I instill that work
ethic yeah I think it's very important I
would worry if I was a parent that I
would clobber the child over the head
with my values I think as a parent maybe
you find your way because everyone's a
rookie when they first have a kid you're
like what do we do but I would want to
be careful that I wouldn't be too much
like here's how you gotta be like that's
not no no no no it's not you know I
would just be afraid of being too like
here's how you're gonna live your life
20 years ago I would have been that dad
yeah today I have to sing what I've seen
I am very open whether I talk with her
or she's five I speak to her on the way
I have to go to work I love you I had a
meeting at nine so I could drive to
school I think I can say and I'll tell a
behavior for your teachers and keep your
eyes open you know and you don't say
what [ __ ] my mom said to me keep your
eyes open don't let nobody mess with you
today you know there's a scene when
you're AJ Weston and sons Aniki at the
end and you bend over to your son and
you go go outside and remember don't say
nothin to the police no is my mom
growing up oh yeah police were always
around my mom was Bob my mom would pull
me over analyst and remember
don't say dick you don't know not my mom
went to a dance with her sister when she
was 16 the sister was 15 and my mom lost
her and she felt she was responsible for
us and Cuba some when she went outside
to look for you a little sister she was
getting raped my mother took a bottle
broke it and killed the guy stabbed a
guy the guy eventually died they had to
ship her out of Cuba bring it to the
States so that she went up a couple
years later with a Puerto Rican chicks
ID cuz you know there's no 911 there was
no TSA they didn't give a [ __ ] you know
there was a time you just showed up at
the thing and said I have the 7:00 a.m.
flight we you Henri wrong guy mr. wrong
I could use what I would now you have an
ID so when she went back to Cuba she
went under an alias and when she came
back to the states that alias became and
then she opened up a bar and somebody
else had to do the finger prints for the
whole [ __ ] that's great
so I story yeah so she named her street
name was her real name was the Laura
Valdez but the street name was Sophia
cecelio D do you go visit kuba no have
you ever been
I left the three and let's just say
let's leave it at that
you know I'm here I'm having a good time
so what if you went back here you get
chopped up or something I think they
wouldn't let me back again okay
I think the government would cuz I went
once I went a few years what did you
think I loved it uh Havana was a
beautiful city the food was amazing
everyone plays an instrument it seems
every bar had an amazing piano player I
met this old woman behind a piano she's
beautiful
and she had a big bowl on her piano for
money tips and whatever and a stack of
her CDs I said I'll buy one of those and
I bought CDs from the local player so
they all have like a CDR of their music
oh my god don't buy all of it this is
like you know eight bucks and you help
em you know it helps the local music
scene and I had one of the a great great
lesson that I get when I tried to bend
about a hundred countries I go pretty
far and what I was thrown in a van with
a bunch of people from Chicago to get
around I kinda had to be part of a tour
group
I missed the lobby call to go visit some
farm that Fidel like winked at many
years ago so we have to go see
I mean anything Fidel touched you have
to go look at it it was a bit of a
propaganda tour when I was there I saw I
missed the lobby call back a minute and
I asked the guy in the lobby I said did
you see a fan yeah your van just left
but he looked at the itinerary said ok
your vans gonna be at this farm in three
hours we'll get you to that farm you can
wait it out so they put me in the local
bus you pay like I'm like whatever it is
like 50 cents and they explains they get
this idiot down to this farm and he lost
his tour group and the guy speaks no
English hardly anyone alone in this
little school bus going down some
country rover outside of Havana and he's
trying to communicate with me he said
hello I said hello it shook my hand he's
like reaching over with his right hand
from the steering wheel and he said
baseball
I said baseball we shook hands on
baseball he goes me kuba I said me
America we shook hands on that he's just
we're like toasting with handshakes and
he said you like made it like a jet and
I said yeah it's rice DSD yeah and he
said me know I want yeah I know man I'm
so sorry and we just kept you know
shaking hands and we got to this
intersection where you make a right and
you go to the farm I figured I'll get
out and all his walk it's like three
miles he it's a public bus route he
deviated from the bus route to take me
to the farm and he's kept finding all
the English he knew America good I said
kuba good we shake hands on that I sure
the guys in like 10 times because he
just wanted to be friendly and say we
can get along and so when someone like
wants to demonize a country or says
something about Cooper I said man you
need to shut up because if you went
you'd really like it and I had this
great moment with this guy just the two
of us on this bus and he dropped me off
at the farm and they were very nice to
me and I sat there and read the
biography on Lincoln for two hours and
waited for the tour group who wondered
how I got there but it was just one of
those great experiences you get when you
get out of the house and you get into
the world but I had a great time in
Cooper at night when I was back in
Havana there's that long sidewalk by the
shoreline with a retaining wall model
okay the kids hang out there because
there's nothing to do
it's like a boombox and they just
they're dancin yeah this being young and
beautiful and yeah I'm some old man
walking by and I would just walk amongst
them just watching them be young and
this is what you do on it at night you
just hang out with each other got the
music and I would just kind of walk
amongst them every night and just kind
of take it in and the air was great and
I'd love to get back there you know you
uh do not consider yourself a religious
person well over the years for me
listening to you I believe in the
Stooges you believe I believe in Iggy
Pop so ah you know you do so many great
things you believe in artists you know I
always say that I'm not a comedian I'm
gonna carve a business and when did that
hit you a yeren I mean you say some
beautiful things you know you support
you know that those three guys living in
a van by their [ __ ] house yeah you
know you was that guy in the van yeah me
too we're all organized that van so I
mean when did it come to you that we're
not in the in the entertainment business
or into karma business early on for me I
come from punk rock and so I've been in
that world as you know die making
records or whatever since I was 18 and
the kind of music I always did the kind
of writing I've done it's all like hard
on sleeve kind of writing where people
come up that book you wrote man it got
me through 11th grade I can't thank you
enough okay or that helped me I wanted
to kill myself but I put that record on
I got through and so people have laid a
lot of really intense information on me
like like just stories that'll kill
you're long and from that you know I
have a very human view of humans as
abusive as they can be as as infuriating
as they can be on the news I have these
stories you know that where I'm like man
that guy's just cried in front of me and
told me about his friend who killed
himself and they used to go to my shows
and he misses them and I can't help but
like people because eventually you hang
out with anyone as someone you hate the
most you'll get a story out of them you
know Wow okay
you're all right you just like really
made some bad decisions I'm not excusing
bad behavior but as angry as I can get
with homeless a
like people at the DMV in line you know
there's like those moments are I kill
them all
III keep coming back to the people I've
met in my journeys through Africa who
have nothing they'll give you half of it
just Azhar kind or your losses like the
walk you back to the main road just
because they don't want you having a bad
day and I've had so many experiences
like that it keeps the guardrails on my
road where this angry as I get him I god
I know there's that guy I met in Haiti
he was real cool and that's where I made
me want to be a better person so being
talked to and told stories and traveling
a lot like going to I've been to every
continent and traveling like that kind
of rough out you see a lot of tough
existences being endure by humans and
that hasn't softened me up it's made my
idea of humanity evolved and so that's
that's helped me with everything from my
writing what I say onstage informs what
I say onstage informs like columns I
write from what I've seen out in the
world so you know in this country it's a
great country but we don't travel as
much as I'd like us to so when you hear
some people they'll talk about some
country or some landmass and they'll
like well they're all like this like so
when was the last time you went well I
didn't go like well so you really don't
know what you're talking about cuz I was
there I'm no expert but that part of the
world invented geometry it was the first
country who ever had translators for
they could have books in different
languages so don't write them off as
people who are scratching in the sand
that that fast and and so it's kind of
this life experience but in an
extracurricular way like I when I'm not
on stage like you know you tour right or
touring gets me like 19 to 21 countries
per tour like Europe America Canada
South Africa New Zealand Australia Kiev
Russia wherever but it's all the
extracurricular travel I do just to go
see a place and that's what got me to
kuba that was what got me to Haiti
Pakistan North Korea places like that I
so I just go and dig the humanity I'm
not much on nature like the mountains
that's nice but I like cities and
watching human mechanics like I make in
your living where do you live you live
in that can I come in can I see how you
get through your day like hiking through
the slums in Bangladesh
like four days and just like go okay
what do you do for a living how do you
make this work and that kind of thing
has really informed me how it informs my
politics and just kinda the world and
how we go forward as a race as a species
what I see with you that's fascinating
is that you know most [ __ ] people go
to Hawaii or you know it's the flesh
guys that's all good too and they go to
Greece and have the olives not you
you're going somewhere with this [ __ ]
something going on [ __ ] yeah Mike we're
going into you know something where
there's something going on that's
lighter and hopefully without an
internal what's the fear is there any
fear level when you go to these places
that you might know just an awareness
and studying any place I go to
beforehand and study mainly for the
culture so if you're a single Western
male in an Islamic country there's a few
ways of the road that will really help
you if you're alone with a camera a nice
camera you got something you need to
protect and so you don't walk up to a
woman oh hey how do I get back to my
hotel ask a man hey just don't don't
walk up and talk to a woman is this not
the way of the walk there so learn where
you where you're gonna be going learn
and always be polite politeness you're
especially I have no backup when I'm in
these places politeness goes a long way
but being culturally aware alleviates a
lot of uncertainty so you gotta know how
to be polite and not to blow it and get
on anyone's nerves especially if you're
like walking the streets of a city alone
where there's like tough guys who want
to roll you come out of time I I'm not
gonna fight me on I wanna fight I just
wanna get me and my camera in and out of
that place and so it's a bunch of
preparation but fear no I'm not a tough
guy but I I just don't have a fear
quotient really you know I used to go it
up I had friends growing up and I would
go to Harlem before in the morning that
I can buy an eight ball or machine gun
or a bazooka
I'm the coke and my friends would go you
know how the [ __ ] do you do that are you
not scared and just because I think I
saw that on the side didn't make me
scared that's why you have no fear of it
yeah you kinda have to know where you
are and you know don't be naive you can
get cut up anywhere I mean we're in
Southern California is a pretty rough
patch of real estate I've almost been
killed here a couple of times and so you
just need to be just kind of always
aware bring your New York with you I
mean if you get mugged like you didn't
see that coming that guy was
telegraphing a block away
he sized you up and I you know you've
seen like three guys one guys the muscle
one guy's the lookout one guy's the
distraction I've seen the three I've had
one time in bhopal in India like the
three guys are doing the thing I make I
said oh so you're the discretion there's
the muscle and there's a lookout right
and they're like ah ah dude well I said
good try though good try I used to live
in New York I've seen it I saw you guys
when you walked in and so you need to
just kind of know just be looking around
did you ever go to Brazil like when they
just had the Olympics there I saw them
doing the pickpocketing and like they
were regret like not it's not trying to
hide it but like really aggressive in
Brazil you gotta watch it that's a place
where even I don't want to walk around
at night cuz I'm just not looking to get
cut up like good good wisdom for
traveling in Brazil never leave your
hood like I leave with no money like
that's how you get stabbed forty to
sixty bucks
have something they can take so they go
I got over on him I'm not gonna stab
them because if you have nothing like so
always go out with a little bit of money
leave the watch and the ID but bring
some money so when you do get robbed you
have a little something you're
absolutely right yeah we've something
for the mouse we've always said that
yeah as a former thief on the other well
you had something I'm taking something
you gotta leave something you gotta give
him some here I left because and you got
a thousand in your sock do you
understand me the real guy got a genome
this suck who's gonna take the shoe if I
ain't got that type of time yeah when I
go for his partner he's got the small 40
can I go off I'm robbing in volumes I
got four guys at $40 that's [ __ ] 160
I'm doing something the party doesn't
turn you off for gummy maybe going back
to that
but that doesn't turn you off for
travelling in general no that's part of
the [ __ ] it's part of it and and you
didn't see it coming and you learned a
lesson like I didn't see that guy I got
to go study that Street better and so
having that kind of awareness has really
helped me navigate like when you travel
alone any almost anywhere in Africa man
you better just be looking around
because it's just you know everyone's
looking at you cuz you're not from there
but you do not look local lier Nigeria
is the number one place in the world
where they just rocked you from A to Z
everywhere yeah but the restaurant a lot
of Africa there's just people in need
and they see you when they see your
Western type they just immediately think
money and I'll get his shoes he has more
and you see I watch families there and
like Ville you know and they're in the
city centre or whatever and you just
they're just getting everything people
coming up and putting stuff in their
hand and trying to charge them for it I
saw that a lot when I was in Egypt and
you see those kind of travelers who
don't know how to kind of slip through
crowds and videos it's gotta be way more
low-key they wear nice clothes they just
kind of stick out like peacocks like hey
hassle me and um there's ways to kind of
the street guys will follow you and they
try and get you into conversation you
just kind of politely go nah I'm not the
guy try him you know I'm not I'm not him
no I'm not that guy no this year you
starting a tour in the States
yeah but then you finished a tour
overseas yeah be finicky about 15
December finishing Nike of Ukraine and
what do you do with 1215 you come back
you sit over there for a couple of weeks
just I was thinking of doing I was
thinking of getting out of camp I'll
probably have to go either to Frankfurt
London or Schiphol Amsterdam
that's the airport and from there I was
gonna go I think I'll go to Reykjavik
Iceland so I never been I've already
mapped up the three record stores so I
figure I should I should do that on the
way back I never been and it's a hop I
can be added any one of those airports I
can be there in three to five hours so
how great is that by SAP bloody
Sabbath in the States and then go to
Germany and see the UK release I have
all of them know I'm that guy
unfortunately Rio oh yeah I have to have
every pressing if it's a record I like I
have the test pressing every different
pressing because there's something
different on the label mastered by a
different engineer I'm sadly that guy a
train spotter but for regular your this
anti Hollywood guy I heard that you live
very modestly very plainly but you sank
a ton into your music system yeah I
think it's so important to you what
unfuckin like I love you that listen
this is my life yeah I would have done
this I just didn't have the patience and
I knew because of the drugs I would have
worn the guitar right I would have
pawned the guitar in the Marshall I know
that already go on in I ended up with
this because at 32 this is it right this
was it well the microphone is screwed
into the tables yeah this is it but this
was my original dream it's so weird how
I I don't understand how people this is
my therapist I don't need to go to a
[ __ ] therapist I could sit down put
on that Hound by Richard Pryor it wasn't
something I said and it could take me
back to that time period yep and I can
know exactly what I was thinking I could
feel the sorrow from that time period I
could feel the happiness from that time
period and I get to deal with it
that way you know whenever I put like
we'll have what master reality first a
perfect record I bought master reality
and I went and I did
THC crystal which is basically gorilla
tranquilizers and the head of acid and I
put master reality island for some
reason The Exorcist was on so I put the
Exorcist
I put master reality on the cans and I
had the Exorcist on and act like the
third so I took master reality open I'll
ever listen to it again you do know that
like I was like this is your hurt again
ever oh no like four years later I got
the balls it's like when I first bought
house it a holy no quarter I skipped
over it right to the [ __ ] we got four
all right
but you can't waste any whatever I
wasn't ready for for for no quarter at
12 at 18 once I didn't hit acid I was
ready for the whole quarter but it was
so weird how master reality I was not
ready for but the purpose of the story
I'm telling you is this is my sign I
drew me to away that's when I met my
happiest is uh when I put on a record
and I play records when I'm off the road
I try and listen to analog source
literally every single day minimum five
records I also try and buy one two three
records a day one way or the other so
there's always something coming in and
I'm always listening what the [ __ ] do
you go you just go to a me bow I for
catalogue stuff like say some band I
like they make a new record I just wait
for it to come out I go but I buy a lot
of rare records so I'm on bidding on
eBay against some other loser male and
so I have a lot of those kind of records
coming in old punk rock from Scandinavia
and buying those records that's all
mail-order discogs eBay but I try and
listen to my Atlas listen to records
last night I'll be listening to records
tonight I got I'm going to two shows
over the weekend so I'll be watching
live music but I try and listen to music
every day and it's I immediately become
happier when I have to music okay so yes
the Heppell on that new hot band
venogram Rena van will have upon two of
their songs okay but the new leads up
one great I last night all night I
didn't go out last night I stayed home
and then when I listened to earlier I
listened to some the b-52s first out
great record I have it on vinyl but I
was at home so it was on YouTube and
like I I went right back to 1980 I went
right back to the [ __ ] place I went
to see him New Year's Eve when I ate a
bunch of quaaludes with my buddies and I
remember the original guitar played yeah
you know on that of the like his licks
on my Private Idaho and I get to the
point where I can't lie to you or the
people at home like this times I go when
I'm listening to an album let's say
black so I would never say die okay I go
through the emotions like never say die
makes me happy Johnny blade makes me
happy great saw uh you're coming home
again tomorrow what's that one I'm sorry
it won't be for long with all the pain
I've watched you to live with him huh
I forget once I get to that much I God
Julia's eyes yeah once I get to join his
eyes I start tearing I start crying
yeah there's songs I on records I have
to skip them cuz like you're gone
there you go there's a song on volume
four changes tremendous I can't hear it
cuz I broke up with a woman I'm still
friends with but when we were slowly
breaking up and I put that song I'm like
I'm never gonna be able to hear this
again and it's been 30 years and I put
it I can't I guess can't well I would
give Li the acid and the drugs I
wouldn't put on changes and I would tell
me to go through some changes
totally better real quick before I of
the second half he had him like he had
everyone in there me everyone in this
was a Tennessee Jazz Festival in
Switzerland somewhere Germany and in a
less than a minute we're all in the palm
of his hand I'm like what is this he
just has you and he's charismatic he
sings great that it took the charisma I
was like what just happened to me I'm in
this guy's lap he was incredible I don't
think I've ever experienced anything
like that and the whole all of us has
kind of leaned into him is amazing no
I'm the type of person that's very hard
for me to get a proper out of me but I
give props what they do and in my world
where I've been and where I've seen you
are the real deal and I tell you this
because it's like most people do things
a certain way you did it backwards and
when I say backwards I mean that you
know I he's getting into comedy now so I
love him like a little brother we've
been working together for seven years
I'll take a bullet for this guy he knows
he knows I agree I break his balls but
he knows I breathe for him I he also got
hospital needs a lung if they take that
long with THC and then whatever and his
body
it's his so I try to keep him under my
wing I pad
from in a way I don't want him to go
through the pain I went through his
economy which is wrong he asked or I
told me a day you gotta go to Oklahoma
I'm gonna see how JEWS doing Oklahoma
you know I'm saying before you can play
New York I do [ __ ] Oklahoma if you
can't do Oklahoma then you got to keep
going back to Oklahoma do you figure out
how would you can play Oklahoma they're
not Lenny Bruce's face on my Ohio yeah I
told you be even Jew in New York and LA
is all right
once you go deep they'll come up to you
and touch it man we ain't never touched
it you a person before yeah I guess so
here you are this kid Haagen Dazs
whatever the [ __ ] you know you're not
doing drugs you're working Black Flag
audition you're in front of these [ __ ]
punk rock people that the kids today
have no idea like they got to see
Soundgarden Pearl Jam with the pit and
jump it and that's one thing but when
you guys endured in the 70s and early
80's was brutality
means a different brutality and ID and
I'd be a kid and I couldn't wait for
Martin the [ __ ] so I would be by the
basketball courts and Martin the [ __ ]
would catch the New York bus about 8:00
7:00 and 7:30 which meant he had a walk
past 38th Street Park about 6:00 I
wouldn't even go home to eat just to ask
Martin the [ __ ] where you gonna go see it
tonight and he tell me black flag that
he wouldn't say bike ride I'm just
saying he would say you know it was dick
you know they all had weird names you
know here I'm starting it cuz I was such
a Catholic but I wouldn't listen to
white music Led Zeppelin and they would
devil music so I would listen to black
music at the time I would listen to a
lot of Earth Wind and Fire and just the
temptations and she lied all good but
something about punk rock [ __ ] me up a
little bit like there was no video there
was no one TV but just the fact that
people were yelling and and so I would
go to them who are you going to see
tonight he would tell me I had to stop
and get Papa's at East West that was the
big record store in Union City if you
ever go to getting say they had all the
anybody who played the garden that's
where you would buy the
the illegal [ __ ] the full of people tape
the concerts oh this is what concert
cassettes the bootlegs the bootleg yes
you would buy him at East West so you
know why Bonzo's birthday party that's a
great one that's famous that's a famous
one you know the drive over and over
again the drummer from Led Zeppelin and
you know I would ask him all these
[ __ ] questions and yeah he was gay
and it was tough being a gay man in 1975
and six you know what some weeks he'd
have a black eye some weeks he'd have a
missing tooth it was always something
with him you know so here you are young
man come on in front little audiences
and then you go on from these [ __ ]
coming then gorillas these people at
these punk rock concerts and you even
said it that you learned a lot when you
won up in front of there's a big dip
between three hundred and fifty people
then thirty five hundred people I think
you got you boiled it on fire they would
pull your hair you learned how to
control an audience yeah yeah there's no
barricade a lot of shows and so people
just can come right up and just hit you
I mean or on my legs there's I have
scars of cigarette and cigars that was
able just put them into my legs some
they would take their keys and try and
stab you and delicate parts of your body
if you shaved my eyebrows you'd see lots
of scars and that's the one here that
belong from Berlin that's this is from
Brazil I need myself in the head and
Santos and broke my head open but the
one here that's a boot the one here
that's another Buddha got kicked in the
mouth I mean ashtrays cans fists with
rings someone just walk up and just like
punch you in the face and like and their
friends go yeah you're like that's I'm
bleeding and I didn't have the money to
get stitched up so I'd give like the
clinic or whatever a fake name and just
sit in there and get stitched up and
finally I just uh I stopped bothering so
I got these crazy scars on my head from
like things being thrown or people
coming up and hitting you and that was
the first five years I did music with
Black Flag the audience's could be
pretty hostile and that was in America
Canada Europe they're just you know
you'd get you know some drunk guy or you
know when you're young you know we're
old
but when you're young it's that Ram at
the base of the mountain in spring where
the 20 year old has to fight the other
one like I'm gonna kick your ass after
the show like really am i back in school
waiting for 3 p.m. and like these if I
had a dollar for every time a skinhead
girl would come up to the van in the
afternoon or in some parking lot of some
bar or playing my boyfriend's gonna beat
you up after this show I'm like okay
thanks and like that guy would
materialize at least half of the time
you know I owe ya I heard about you and
you have to get into it and then load
the gear up
my introduction to you was really on our
ease podcast I was really the first time
I really sat down and listened to you
and I looked you up and I I've been with
in podcast for six years and I hate
there's a very happy thing where people
talk about hate online now but when I
looked you up they were talking about
you having a fight during the show
fighting the audience and I I get blowin
even hecklers are like that's the top
for me like a heckler
I can't imagine during the middle of a
show punching like having to have a
fistfight with an audience member it was
it got so utilitarian like okay get
through the course got the course
there's a lead BAM hit him and get back
before the bridge because you know you
could have to pop this guy because he
keeps swinging at your head like okay
I gotta get through the verse otherwise
the guitar player will be you know I'll
get a demerit or whatever so you just
became like it's Tuesday evening crack
back to the song where you just it just
became part of your like I don't I don't
have a stomach for that kind of thing
I'm really not looking to get that in
that situation so I'm not good at it but
by 85 I got another night another buck
what's up guy it was old neutralizing
and not starting anything it's always
like neutralizing the thing or the guy
waiting for you after this sure like I
have to neutralize this guy because I
still have to load the gear out I still
have to drive to Nebraska and sleep in a
Denny's parking lot next to another
smelly male and we're all just drawing
off from this show it was that life you
live when you're 20-something and you
know you're kind of bomb-proof and you
can do it you get to speak to anybody
from the back way no only through
attorneys it's you know it's it's the
modern age we only get together to
litigate
now in 96 when you opening Fozzie yeah
how's Creighton he became cuz I can't I
gotta tell you though my mom died at 16
I was lost and between sabotage the
sound behind me mega mania I had I was
in love with this girl and every time
her and I would have a fight I'd take a
hit of acid and go home and listen to
megalomania that was my breakup song and
I'm saying I don't know what he what is
he saying that you know what song I'm
talking about a [ __ ] man you know that
whole [ __ ] things and now instead I
won't be laid by you now [ __ ] man
like that whole thing that was my
process every time I broke up with the
[ __ ] girl and you just toured with
this lunatic and to him he was your
world I mean what was that like the
first time I met us how did you even
mean it um he
we got the offer to do some shows of the
Ozzy and I every wrong his band roles
been and I said yes on behalf of my band
mates and they were kind of lukewarm
into it we're in the middle of trying to
write an album so I said okay relearn
the set we're going down the floor to
play with Ozzy they're like really and
I'm like yeah throwing my weight around
but and the in smile we're playing with
Ozzy I want to meet that guy since I was
like what 12 so we go to this like
20,000 you know like his home are these
mega places and where you take the golf
cart like four floors down underneath
the field where the utilitarian dressing
rooms are like those showers with 480
people and we're sitting under these
fluorescent lights on the benches and
there's an apple a can of coke and like
a banana that's like the backstage Wow
the big time and the door explodes open
and in comes Aussie with a cigar in one
hand easily which one of you guys is
under rose about I said I am thank you
for being on the tour I hope you have a
really good time
the PA is really big as the late as loud
as you want blue you want to have a
great time you left Andy with the whole
total time seven seconds it was just
fantastic and I'm like wow I just met
Ozzy Osbourne's like this hurricane and
all he could smell this tobacco that the
cigar and so I said to the guys in the
band I said fellas no one in this career
wants to see us they only want one band
it was like Type O Negative us and then
Ozzy and so we played no one threw
anything at us I was like okay
and I went up you know showered and ran
back up to the top to watch Ozzy because
I'm a fan and he's standing on stage
right where if he goes to his left he'll
be walking onto the stage and the band's
out there and he's kind of standing
there and I walk up the hey Ozzy how you
doing
is there anyone out there I said it's
like 25,000 people I mean yeah it's
packed I said what do you mean is there
anyone out there he's like I always get
nervous no one's gonna show up I said
when is what any of you ever had that
problem he said I can't remember I just
get you know I get depressed all day
worrying if anyone's gonna show up know
what Wow I said no I think there's a few
in there and he said went back to kind
of like just standing there with his
hands in front of him I'm like okay well
just stand here with you he went that
like this weird statue like state then
Sharon Osbourne comes up like just she's
just your dentures fly out of your mouth
just yelled at he look huh Julie get out
there and he was just kind of spacing
out and waiting for her to give him the
shove and he kind of walks out there the
flick the switch is flicked and he
becomes like let's go crazy and the
place went completely bananas and they
went into whatever the first song was
and I watched him a couple of nights and
it's like so much fun just watching him
with that audience because the affection
they love that guy but he loves them too
and it was really fun
and I flew after that first night I I
flew on the family jet to the private
island the hotel they're staying active
I was gonna stay with him and it was
just like living the osbourne lifestyle
for like a few hours was trippy I mean
it has the Aussie logo on the side of
the jet the pilots waiting
good evening Aussie how was your show
and we drank diet Pepsi's as we flew to
some designer Island and he told me how
they made the paranoid album and just he
told me this great story about recording
paradise how long were you on the tour
well like half a week that's it yeah it
was all we were offered you know they
probably just didn't have a band for
that slot for like these show
and they threw it out to my manager and
like we were lucky type o-negative was
the other band on the bill great great
band great and really great and I don't
know if they had more shows like the
next time I saw Pete Steele like a year
later we just didn't I didn't ask him if
he did more shows I think he kind of
knew them before I met them I think he
brightened maybe Ozzfest or something I
think he knew them before but I've known
the Osbourne's ever since like I see
them every few years for something and
like you know Sharon Ozzy the kids are
always like super nice to me like they
always remember my name and that
couldn't be nicer it was like it's I'm a
fan mainly my records I go to shows and
it's great when people that you really
admire for whatever they do that they're
actually cool okay and Ozzy and all the
Sabbath guys actually they're all super
friendly self-effacing they're
extraordinary
actually this hilarious people always
making jokes crazy how you went from
most people had done the other way they
were God spoken word you went from this
violent [ __ ] punk rock world and to
this cool guy on stage telling your
thoughts with nobody punching you in the
face now nobody line your balls if I
think a little friendlier now and now
you know because I I'm gonna forget a
verse from eternity
78 they started having problems Joe
Perry left yeah was replaced Brad would
more left
yeah let's record which allowed people
don't like and I kind of like but then
they did the Knights of the rut store
and it was the rush I saw them open for
Ted Nugent like in 76 and they weren't
really that good in years later Nugent
opened for them
I can't believe that [ __ ] well who's
bigger than Aerosmith so no and I went
to see Aerosmith at a place called the
soap factory in Richfield New Jersey
down from the Chan's dragon and my
friend best Chinese restaurant in the
[ __ ] country they just made the top
30 restaurants in New Jersey calm the
best general tiles cat you've ever had
in your [ __ ] life you understand me
they've been there the best egg rows
but I went to see Aerosmith death at the
soap factory which is like your local
which was very sad it was on the way up
and everybody was really bad well Steve
was yeah Steven was beautiful than he
was but he had some challenges I saw
them the first time I saw them was when
Walk This Way was the single so that was
the deadly boys in the attic door first
Reno show ever saw they opened with rats
in the cellar it's a good show we're in
the cheap seats so we got like kind of
broken sound and kind of wrapped rockets
through the hockey arena and when it
finally gets to you you don't know what
song it is
so as a does the smell of cheap arena
weed and arrows is spent like two
seconds later the slap back but it was
cool I told I met I met Steven Perry
years later and told him the story and
he appreciated it the same same place I
saw Nugent and Van Halen and Led
Zeppelin is its it it was the local
hockey arena it's gone now there's it I
think a bigger one in this race yeah
Largo the capital Center Clark this is
why solid Zeppelin and I saw Van Halen
on their first album tour open for
Nugent I saw him walking through as a
Sabbath oh yeah now see that was a
disaster
yeah I've seen photos of them as a group
shot all doing the camera I still
remember Bill Ward snorting in between
like like I we were sitting so close to
the right hand side or the left hand
side right that I remember watching him
like him between takes like just put
some on the Senedd from and do a [ __ ]
line and me sitting there going holy
[ __ ] that is tremendous but they're
horrible doing homegoing was that they
never say diet when I was at yes
overhaul did a [ __ ] jazz band he
didn't like he doesn't like never say
almost every show from that tour got
bootleg - yeah and I have cassettes and
LP they sound really they're playing
everything really fast cuz the whole
thing the whole band was coked but
they're going through everything like
one point something speed like it's like
whoa guys slow down it was the same set
like rock and roll doctor all those
songs but at that every show on that on
that tour got bootleg and I've got at
least 10 or 15 shows from that tour
just cuz they're available bootlegs in
the 80s for cheap they'd like to LP
bootlegs same set every time so right
now Pavillion what do you say you got
now some of the hours big question I've
never measured by number it's a it's a
lot it's just walls of them and then
there's a boxes of singles lot of
singles and tons of cassettes there's
lots of music media and six stereo
systems iced remember he pees buying the
RATP yeah
buying missing persons EP right with
Terry Bozzio on the drums or whatever
his name was
we had the Sun on rainin yeah he's a
Zappa disciple yes yes Joseph school a
tremendous monster drummer monster
draggable one of the guys that stuck out
like when I saw them yeah Steve Aya's
from those you know the day that those
days of Zappa he's another incredible
musician really good guy I met him last
year great guy how was it shooting heat
it was I want to talk to you two more
things and we'll get Johnny I mean you
guys I'm not Mary I'm more on your
schedule truly I have a this is a short
story but it's a real good one I'm
trying to remember her cuz you 85 was 80
94 was a ray of you shut mnemonic
youngish I and I was on tour with a band
with the big we had a big single that
year it was a great great year on every
possible level of a young man on tour
before shows after shows during the day
everything was fantastic and we're
making money so I could pay the band in
full we were living well everyone got
their own own hotel room on a night off
which was kind of a that took a while
for us to get to that so we're touring
comfortably but we're playing hard and
so things were really good and somewhere
in 94 95 I'm trying to remember the nice
casting person she's really popular we
have very very well known anyway she
brings me in to read for a part for heat
and it's one of those things you get
there noon you get there at 11:45 for
the noon like look either running late
I'm like really I should just go so I'm
not getting this part she came out and
said okay you're gonna get this part I
really want you for this michael mann's
listens to me
so just hang out calm down I was like
getting all pissed off that I'm waiting
so as
you know two hours wait because it is
what it is like walk-in I do the lines
he goes okay you're fine but you have
scenes without Pacino and I have a very
tense set because but at that point
apparently but you know in DeNiro they
don't get along for some reason it's not
my business no one told me anything but
tension they said um I don't need any
more tension so you're gonna get this
part if Al Pacino likes you I said okay
what does that mean he said you're gonna
meet up with chin not if he likes you
you can have the part if he doesn't like
you then you gotta go cuz I can't have
one more iota of tension on this set I'm
gonna I said okay so what how am i what
is what's gonna happens is you're gonna
have lunch with Al Pacino I said okay so
when do we set that up he's a relief
right now if we left the building when
we go to some restaurant near we're in
like Century City and all of a sudden
there's out Pacino I said mr. Pacino I
mean like I didn't know what else to
call him I said mr. Pacino how do you do
call me al call me ow I said okay oh wow
and we had this great lunch he's
hilarious he's really friendly and at
the end of the lunch he looked at
Michael mrs. Michael I liked him
that's how I got the part and every day
I had scenes of him there's one scene
where my body double got thrown through
the window right that was not me it was
my stunt double who actually had to go
get stitched up he cut his head open
after the second take anyway so there's
that part where they cuffed me because
I'm a bad guy and they wait not get like
hauled out and they were in the same
with the Indian also welcome to get you
Wes Studi
yeah yeah yeah yeah get you in the
apartment so that scene ends with me
cuffed in so Michael man Phil so the
cuffs are real the guns are real the bad
guys are real bad guys everything's real
and so I'm really cuffed behind my back
sitting on this couch waiting for props
to come and uncuffed me over and over
like 80 takes and it's a big film I'm
low priority so it's like minutes to get
uncuffed so I'm just sitting there
cuffed Al Pacino would sit and keep me
company he's a really nice guy he could
have gone you know and done something
else he would sit with me and just mess
with me put his arm around me give me a
magic marker I'm gonna
- mhmm and he was just so cool to me
every morning Henry how are you I'm like
I'm better now how are you not so good
and he tell you what's the matter and he
was nice to everyone on that set and
that was just a huge moment for me as
like some BS artist actor and taking
lessons I just [ __ ] I totally Jesus I
always get worried that the Hollywood
cops are gonna come in like alright come
here in my god dammit they figured it
out and I'm just everyday I'm on that
said like what am I doing here
and it was just a great thing you know
people love that movie and even in
airports to this day they gone you were
that dude in heat right I'm like yeah
thanks
and that was just a lucky break as a
small part anyone could have done it but
um it was just really cool to have those
moments and watch Michael Mann work I
mean he's a genius director now a did
you have anything would do they were on
them
no sir only a phone call well we both
did voiceovers thing right yeah who are
you talking to a dead man on the line
and then you watch the movie we're
having a conversation but um if I was I
did a Colbert a couple of years ago and
he was on before me and they kind of get
him in and out of the building you never
see him and I wanted to meet him of
course and then I wanted to say hey we
had that distended conversation in heat
now that would have been my opening line
but I never got to meet him you know
it's funny I did two movies with him the
first time I didn't really have any
contact with him I saw him and I saw his
social problem like he has like that he
can't be around crowds it was as he
seems like he keeps himself to you so so
Michael Rapaport has the funniest joke
of the year he says that DeNiro didn't
say nothing for 30 years until Trump
became president now he's talking John
Trump made me zero talks interesting to
him thirty [ __ ] years for him to say
anything but to see him on like talk
shows like Colbert whatever like whoa
gah like you'd see him doing tours to
promote a movie and he's so
uncomfortably all calm he just doesn't
want to do it no he just wants to do the
work I think he didn't like I saw him
one time and it was so
bad that I saw him dude
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh when he got the actor
studio
oh god the guy would hassle the question
he'd go you know what it is just not
that guy just not that guy this wants to
do the work he's a true artist and it's
so funny when no I think that we all
have a little thing I all think we all
yes sir okay that that I'm an only child
so you you know it's time to go into
your room that's most the time that's
most of time and that's what you you
know we all have this young in this yet
and we shine and the yang and our yang
is where we don't shine and his acting
abilities and his little things are
great and you know I at that time they
shot The Sopranos in Jersey on that same
[ __ ] Street so when they found out
they were shooting analyze that they
went down there they had to be you know
nine thousand people on the streets I'm
shooting my scenes when I have Phelan
pocket I got nothing to do with the
narrow but I just want to get a glance
of the guy and at one time he didn't
know that these nine hundred people were
out in front of his trailer and he
opened the door and it was like he's
seen I hate [ __ ] just slam Bobby
Bobby come on he was like well that's it
but you know that's not cool to have a
trailer where they just didn't know the
logistics they didn't know it wasn't
anybody's fault they didn't know that
The Sopranos shot in Kearny New Jersey
they didn't know anything whatever I've
been in a film with big talent man you
can't get ya know you can't get near him
but this this is just a folk yeah yeah
yeah because we were shooting two
cameras at once so you had a beasts
camera you know why shot spider-man 2
they were shooting be an a well I
breezed a get it done yeah he's getting
it done it's a 200 million dollar [ __ ]
budget so we're ripping you can amortize
it down to an hourly rate I learned that
on bad boys to they said you know this
movie takes this much are you an hour to
make I was like I never thought of it
that way
producers do are you kidding oh yeah you
know have you ever shot in New Orleans
no I've done a lot of shooting the one
leads was funny all right Pete James
Gandolfini
he threw the JI he did a
Shawn who played the piccoli Jeff
Spicoli something Sean Penn movie and he
went to a strip club the night before
and somebody put a roofie in this thing
huh
and he didn't wake up and make the scene
and he had to pay the day rate the day
rate was four hundred fifty thousand
yeah he paid it because he was loud
there he said died before you yell at me
I just don't like doing this apprentice
I just pay the day right well is it
because he disappeared from the surprise
for three days and Wow
yeah they just had the autopsy of James
Gandolfini on truTV whatever they have
all time you ever watch that you know
they have the autopsies or like the
final hours or people oh yeah and I seen
that I didn't know they had the final
and I watched it just to see if they
would talk about the drug problem that
was existent oh I didn't know yet I said
yeah nobody really knew they had I heard
it because I'm a druggie yeah I'm a
druggie so I knew people in New York
that's at all you [ __ ] Nazi but just
but uh what the [ __ ] were we talking
about here and was my consciousness in
New Orleans New Orleans where what was
the daily rate the hourly rate like it's
[ __ ] huge yeah it's no joke that's
why you're never late to things like
that because I you know I'm never late
anyway but uh you see what these
producers are up against because they
got Sony or someone breathing down their
neck and then you haven't you know a
difficult actor he's not coming out of
his trailer like haha no I know I've
been in films were he's not coming out
of his trailer for another hour because
he didn't get his 12 hour turnaround and
he's he's mad and uh Henry do you mind
doing your scene to a different actor I
said man just give me a c-stand with a
smiley face on a post-it I'll just do
the scene just keep moving see you and I
are very happy I've noticed that and all
the things I watched about you happy
when I'm working even on Rogan you said
something that it was so therapeutic
that I did it recently and I'm a better
comic for it I'm a better dad for it a
little better or everything for it you
know I'm a [ __ ] criminal you know I
went to prison
I got a GED I left not gonna send my
grade my mom died and I focused on that
and I'm Rogen you said that one day you
wrote a list of all of the album's you
wrote the books you wrote
the music you wrote the movies you in
the TV shows you are in and I did that
recently I was feeling like [ __ ] before
I shot the Netflix special and I have to
worry even worse you know I wasn't gonna
pull a [ __ ] Bourdain I'm not known for
that I'm a [ __ ] Catholic I can't
leave here to go to hell if you're
already in hell but I actually did what
you said and I look at my
accomplishments I stopped looking at the
person who I was and I started looking
who a person I became hmm because of
your oh wow what's so I just wanna let
you know that that list just got me over
one of the toughest times of my life
hmm at the age of 55 I didn't look at
you know that's why I always tell
comedians get a [ __ ] day job because
we need don't have a day job you don't
think about what you have you think
about what you don't have Henry Rollins
just got heat well how come I don't
[ __ ] have heat you know why you don't
have heat because you're not [ __ ] in
a day job you wouldn't be thinking about
Heat you'd be thinking about [ __ ]
working
and now the time that you do have you're
more focused and what the [ __ ] you need
to do instead of spreading your dance
111 out nobody's cover 11 hours when
they're a comic there's gonna be some
porn there's gonna be some you porn
jerking off there's gonna be some music
but if you have something for five hours
that takes your mind off of the things
that you don't have you've always been
you know exactly who you are
there's no faking you you didn't show up
with nine agents I mean from A to Z
you're just a gentleman I try I had good
days Betty I know we all do we all do
but you like I said you have you're the
reason why I do allow this [ __ ] away
after I saw you on Rogan you simplified
a lot of [ __ ] for me for somebody who
didn't like school you're a [ __ ]
genius where it's necessary like who
gives a [ __ ] about geometry you are what
intelligence really is you are a circle
I'm not blowing smoke up your ass you
know so I'm really happy that you took
the time although that I don't want to
say the word
it's a shitty word they gotta watch it
because you're the artist that you are
on set or ggest tenth you have something
coming out on a Showtime
why do what's the what's the it's called
keep talking keep talking [ __ ] no
more [ __ ] word and I'll stab you in
the eyeball yeah that's it that's it
yeah go change the title and this is
spoken war you know it's this what I do
up there a lot of it's funny I'm not
very funny I don't write funny material
I just kind of comment on that which is
funny so I just report from the field
and sometimes it's funny but sometimes
it's not it's very funny because it's
subtly funny yeah I never whine about
work that you didn't want your life to
be a Bruce Springsteen lyric yeah almost
died and I was a little called you at
home and said no because I grew up on
Bon Jovi you know well let's pray what's
that song robust amount will break their
hearts forever forever never say goodbye
that's New Jersey lyrics hey you know
we'll break that we'll bust out we'll
leave and we'll break their hearts you
know we'll get out of this [ __ ] dump
you know you use that describe your work
thing if you didn't want to be a PI
laugh my ass off I don't know what video
you said yeah when I was young I was
like I'm gonna be a big guy in the song
you know I'm gonna knock up the local
girl and I'm just gonna see the end of
my life every day in this in us in a
place like this you know whatever
minimum-wage job we'll be scraping away
at and eventually you know I'll screw up
with a girl and all of a sudden I'll be
a dad and I'll be that guy in the song
you know let's get the [ __ ] outta prison
I got married I'd had a job as an
estimator I thought that was the
American Way my mother came from [ __ ]
humour for me to live this way and I
think I would have died of boredom
yeah I'm not putting the working man
down I don't wouldn't worry I know
there's some people they're just not
friendly in the straight world what you
can't give David Bowie a day job at copy
Matt it's just can't he he can get the
understands how the machines run but he
just can't cope and I realize her
like I'm nuts I'm not gonna hack this to
the real world or the straight world
it's gonna hurt I can do it because I'm
tough enough to hack it but it's gonna
be really unenjoyable I need somewhere I
can be a maniac and that's where music
saved me because like you know it got
like Iggy Pop you can't give a straight
job you'll just burn the place I mean or
you'll forget to show up because he'll
he's this not in part of that world and
it's not putting down anybody I respect
anyone with a job is this that I
realized early on I'm not gonna fit in
man I gotta find something for weirdos
and thankfully I found a whole universe
of work for if you're weird and that's
how I live I'm strange do you still feel
at times they you don't fit in because I
lived that yeah I don't fear it or hate
it I just stopped trying to be bummed
out that I didn't I really wanted to be
like everyone else
like have the normal stuff and I
realized I need to several years ago I
know that's just never gonna be me so
stop trying and failing and wasting
people's times and stop feeling bad
about it because they're not bad and
you're not bad so just go be weird don't
hurt anybody and guys go do your thing
and so I kind of went I am I'm a
stone-cold weirdo so I'll just go get
that work done and not even try to to
hang did you watch Steven Tyler on Joe
Rogan no if you have a chance I will
he's a great storyteller he's seen all
the events you look at the winners in
life and they all have little things
even though they have rough patches no I
mean you have you've lived the life but
I lived
but I lived it with drugs and prisons
and [ __ ] you've suffered you know
with what happened you involved with the
West Memphis PD said well I've had some
ups and downs you lost and you
understand so many things you see so you
witness a very horrible thing happen in
front of you you know I found my mother
dead on the floor with a purple [ __ ]
left arm you know you see all these
things and you have the disposition of
the outlook that you have and it's just
a [ __ ] if if everybody was if more
people will like you we'd have such a
way better earth
well we'd have more traffic jams
probably less efficiency but uh
the music might be good what was your
favorite lineup of the Rollins band all
those years uh the 90 the 87 to 92
lineup because you had the great New
Jersey Trenton New Jersey rhythm section
of Andrew Weis on bass and sim cane on
drums and that was one of the most
amazing rhythm sections I've ever seen
in any band anywhere and they were just
loose and tight at the same time they're
like a slinky there's like elastic and
precise and mathematical but they could
throw it away when they wanted and no
matter what you put on top of them the
me and the guitar player always looked
good because they were so good and then
after that I had a different lineup
which was the same drummer different
bass player Melvin Gibbs who's great in
a different way he's just more just
different amazing but that that one
lineup it just had this elastic Sabbath
p-funk smashing thing that I really
enjoyed we would just go out there and
just like smash audiences flat now you
as eclectic as I am like if I come to
your house with some Hindu on a flute
and I put them on but you give them a
listen to oh I might have more of that
guy's records than you do that's what
I'm yeah yeah I know I'm that guy it's
uh I love music I love I buy it from all
over the world and I and I there's a lot
of bad music I don't like there's a lot
of [ __ ] I don't like them I have
disagreements with people that's they
can't like it all this is not enough
time it's it's been a pleasure
just thank yous to sit with you let me
see if there's anything else I want to
bring up you know the wall with the
smoke and brush getting stabbed the
[ __ ] story you told of the guy
getting stabbed by the show I relate to
you well well in the back of the venue
Marla you didn't want to make it funny
but the guy got stabbed
that's what can kill me because I just
did a show in Nyack where the guy
heckled me got up to go to the bathroom
and tool the fans of the podcast
followed him and hit him in the head
with a bottle and the guy was bleeding
the way up the cops like you want to
pressurize they don't want to run I'm
just happy to be here because this is
the best night of my life yes
I got to meet Joey Diaz and I got six
stitches some [ __ ] you know describe to
people when you're when you're up there
that magic that you feel like I don't
feel I'm better than them
oh no I'm with them yeah for me it's a
service I consider myself like a blender
or a toaster oven I'm a component I'm
like a frozen yogurt machine like one a
pint one a quart I'll go all day
III output and so let me make you radio
show let me put together a great show
and let me go on stage and go on for too
long and really knock it out of the park
I want to go on stage and so I love
being up there and so for me I have an
obsession with the audience and I always
tell us that I I'm so desperate for your
affection in your approval you have no
idea and they always laugh but it's true
I I need them more than they want to be
at the show I really so I don't have
stage fright
I can't wait to go see them I love those
people and when they you know they write
me I gotta write it back I did meet him
on the street since I was young Henry
I'm like yeah bad hey thanks they go hey
Henry thank you my nose I need you more
than you need in here you kiddin
without you I got nothing going on I got
no one to make all this stuff for and so
I've been up since about five o'clock
this morning working on radio shows for
my little radio show on kcrw
I'm sitting there like well that song
has to go after that one okay I'm the
third I love this I'm always in
preparation to do something for you the
audience and so when I'm finally there
with them I love being up there and I
bring a stopwatch onstage so I don't go
on for too long because I'm a gong know
it's like I gotta let you people what
are you like doing we mean how much time
do you think is appropriate for you it's
what I do is not appropriate it's awful
no it's really bad oh my god I tell you
I'm looking into a mirror it's like I'm
listening to my phone look down the
stopwatch and it's like two hours and
seven minutes um I know I have to start
landing this jumbo jet a crap somehow
it's gonna take half an hour to finish
this story even with some edits okay and
here's how I'm gonna end the
and I looked down like two hours 43
minutes I apologize oh my god I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry they're like no no
it's fine I don't know it's not fine you
have a life to go go get out of here go
get back to it
so I think an hour fifty is probably
better it's hard for me to get off stage
more than after like two hours is
minimum and it's just because I don't
wanna so and on the last tour we kept
just trying to shorten the show and
anything that was less than two hours
forty I look at my road man goes I'd
show them to stop RC 233 I'm getting
better and you just laugh you always
change it up your shows like you always
destroy you're doing something different
this this towards really static it's a
bunch of slide so I'm showing through a
high-resolution projector and I'm
telling the story behind the photo so
the the folder of photos does not change
Oh
revolve a few but the story is the story
when I'm on stage just me in a
microphone it's like a setlist for a
band I've got the new album you know the
new material like this story the story
this story but within a month of being
on the roads I usually do like of a
30-day month I do 29 to 30 shows I hate
days off my next run is like 46 shows in
46 days there's a night off what I'm
doing two sets in Portland so I don't
like night saw and you do Mondays and
Tuesdays Wednesdays Thursdays Fridays
Saturdays so you feel that you still get
the most out of the audience on a
Tuesday night it's time as on tours
fluid to me it's all it's always
Saturday night okay so if they're there
Saturday night in New York don't screw
this fee in my mind I want to be on
salary because then I get everybody that
I could to come out I feel like I'm
Monday people gonna go you know what I
gotta work on Tuesday and they do and
you don't always fill the place out but
you get who you get and if you're smart
you're happy they showed up and you you
rock their world that's just me that's
my pillow yeah you know you know what
that's that's that's most performers
they just want to do a good show most
performers I've met no matter what music
or comedy whatever they just want to
kill themselves to do a great show for
the audience they just it's not about
the money or the applauses about doing
something truly good and hoping someone
likes it and and so I'm what was exactly
your question
same stuff every night okay um within
ten shows something has happened in the
news like some country caught on fire
but I was there two years ago so now I
can talk about the last time I was in
Syria and so I'll talk about that or
something happened in this state
well here's what happened to me when I
was in that state or I was there when
that thing on the news happened and so I
can connect the dots so that memory gets
pulled into the set cuz now I can attach
it to this and so within a month of
being on the road I have about six hours
of working material just because I've
been able to associate now I remember
that boom it comes in or I have some
interesting sociological opinion /
theory that I think I want to extol to
the audience and so within ten or
fifteen shows I have too much material
so that's when I start rotating things
through to keep myself kind of leaning
into it though I'm not pulling this ring
out of my chest and doing the talking
doll thing and that way when the
material remains kind of familiar but
not like I do put in that comma in the
same place every night I'm more in the
moment to borrow the actor's term
because I like I said I I'm doing shows
like a year and months at a time and I
have to keep it fresh to myself gives an
audience as you know you can't fool them
they have a canine sense like they know
when you're phoning it in
even if it's one line like I he just
want to be here screw you too and I
can't do that I can't do that from the
audience right you can't do it because
they you know that you think of what
their evening is like they just got out
of cubicle babysitter parking dinner
that's a big night out big neither
paycheck chunk they're like okay this
better be good
and um I think about that it's not their
money I'm concerned about their time
it's they're not I don't concern about
my money I'm concerned about their money
but mainly their time they don't get
this Tuesday night back so it can't be
oh it's a guy on a Tuesday night he's
gonna dial it in oh no no this is your
date night you're going back home to the
kids you're up at 4 a.m. feed the kid go
to the cubicle and in the bad car I get
it so I never dial it in it's always
like you know New York Saturday
not to me listen the problem I had the
last couple months was I had so much
respect for the audience that I wouldn't
let myself be Who I am that's why they
came they came for you to be you that's
right yeah and I'm thinking yeah I'm
trying to be a stand-up I'm not trying
to be in a while man Who I am
yeah just be you and now they got a
[ __ ] problem ever since I did the
list that you did and I did a couple
thinking like I'm only going to the
store you know I only go to the store
because metal sharpens metal
I don't be [ __ ] around no more I was
going all these other comedy clubs and
why why I'm 55 I got a five-year-old I
don't have this much [ __ ] time so now
I'm going up there with predetermined
material but anything that comes into my
[ __ ] heart straight from my balls
that's real I think it's funny whether
it whatever I'm laying not that [ __ ] the
order of the material [ __ ] the
organization I'm gonna give you an hour
of my time but it's gonna rock your
[ __ ] world and part of that was
Europe's mentality the immigrant
mentality and just this podcast to me
keeps me in check what you said when
these people come up to you on the
street and stuff like that they say
thank you for coming like last week I
was in Salt Lake City don't like why
would you come tomorrow and I told
everybody I could feel the love yeah cuz
you're here of course I'm coming I'm
coming here yeah but it's so weird how
when I went to so like I'm so thankful
to be doing like what are you gonna
retire when they put you in a [ __ ]
task yeah I don't I can't I can't think
I'd say I can't think of it well I don't
know what I would do without him like if
I didn't have a tour to get look forward
to or or knowing it's coming up I don't
know I've been touring since 1981
averaging up to about a hundred shows a
year for 30-some years I don't know what
else I just don't know what else to do
with time and I can I can sit around if
I want I got a nice place yeah I got a
record player I can space out on the
couch but I would really miss being out
there it's gonna be hard to walk away
from self still lifting you still a good
and listen I can't wait to August 10th
this has been one of highlights of my
seven year Thank You Sun cast career
just to sit across from somebody who was
no Hollywood [ __ ] it when you get up
in the morning you're two feet hit the
floor you look up and you thank Buddha
or somebody that he gave you another day
for somebody to [ __ ] Rock young
saying like oh my god absolutely so
thank you for AJ Weston thank you for
telling that kid not will talk to the
[ __ ] cops [ __ ] and August 10th
I'll be supporting you and everybody on
this church that listens to this podcast
thank you we'll be supporting you for
the words you said today and you have an
open door took them come in here and do
Elmo whatever you have an open door here
whatever you want to come all right and
Heidi who takes care of you is you're
very lucky that 22 years she's been
running the show very lucky to have her
in your life she's like my wife I look
at it without my wife I'd be [ __ ]
guts I'd be a piece of [ __ ] so I give
her a hug for me and we'll all be
watching okay his tenth brother thank
you and good luck with the tour
oh now once it ends just 15th when you
stre start on the website on Henry
Rollins com yeah the tour only goes to
12 1500 the next big tour all do would
be 20 20 20 20 yeah so you'll take how
much time walk between 1215 in the next
tour
although years oh yeah yeah um the next
tour will be not a slide she'll just be
me and it'll be the big one I do it like
every presidential election year I do
the big lap ru I do like Europe like
three times like festivals
oh no no no non the big month in
Australia it's like you very well there
so I do multiple nights
that's that goes on and off for 14
months so it'll go from 2020 in to 2021
if all goes according to plan I'm
telling you what I'm gonna do today out
of respect for you for the last five
years I've had a guy been bothering his
gentlemen Greg and I have a lot of
people my agents I'm gonna get my
passport
I'm calling the attorney I'm giving up
I'm paying the $10,000 fine I have in
Seattle for
we're not going to uh I got a $10,000
fine I gotta pay Seattle just wants to
10 G's I'd rather [ __ ] get raped in
the ass
by ten little midgets with big dicks
before I pay attendees that's a lot of
mountain going for [ __ ]
anger-management classes the guy
attacked me at a comedy club and then I
gotta go so I'm gonna pay the 10 G's I'm
getting the passport I'm gonna start
traveling because I noticed a certain
beauty you have and it's because of you
travel it helps it really will make you
understand I'll get better I'm done I
love America it's great came here you'll
understand it better when you travel I
love South Dakota I'm going to North
Dakota next year beautiful out there
every spot of this country but sitting
here crushing me for this last hour I
saw something in you that you got from
traveling from meeting that woman in
Tehran
she's amazing for being that Cuban man
and talking baseball baseball you know
so what I love you brother thank you for
inspiring me and you got me I got you
back to the end the [ __ ] time okay
thank you very much and send Heidi my
love oh well
all right I want to thank Henry Rollins
for doing a great job and coming in and
[ __ ] blessing us I want to thank Lee
I don't want to thank you guys but most
importantly I'll forget this Thursday
night Kansas City here I come [ __ ] full
[ __ ] house deemed our race coming
from the East Coast will [ __ ]
parachuting right into [ __ ] Kansas
City at The Improv Thursday 8 o'clock
that's the show to be at Friday Rogen's
in town so I got understand I understand
I ain't manager ain't mad at nobody my
feelings have been hurt before I went to
prison for years but Saturday night I'll
see you then at the Kansas City improv
red eat some [ __ ] ribs farting the
whole [ __ ] deal and then at the end
of the month Hounslow Alabama one night
only Thursday and then I take her
straight up to Nashville the week before
Memorial Day old Labor Day weekend the
summer is almost over [ __ ] and
I'll see you in September and DC at the
9:30 club
[ __ ] parks Casino and then we're at
the wool Betina myself and Lee there's
like 30 tickets left for the second
Chelsea
[ __ ] that a look and we're also a
Connecticut that Fox with Foxwoods on
but there's still tickets there so do
what you need to do I love you guys have
a great [ __ ] Monday thank you for
listening
stay black have a great day